before he was swole
before he was existentially depressed
and before he was a cartoon
never leave the cave without it he was a
small existentially depressed
literal cartoon in
[Music]
batman the animated series
returned to a time when pop culture
wasn't oversaturated with superheroes
they sell t-shirts of me i've become a
cliche
animation still ruled after school and
dial-up internet gave us a few precious
minutes offline
[Music]
and spend some time with kevin conroy's
iconic bruce wayne
an industrialist with the money of tony
stark and the fashion sense of dwight's
fruit
but when night falls this punchaholic
will become the batman
the world's greatest detective who's
also the world's greatest ninja
greatest hacker i've accessed gotham's
electrical mainframe
there's another computer up linked to
this one i'm tracing the link now
greatest magician you've got the makings
of a great
magician and the greatest ventriloquist
when i studied with zatara the magician
he taught me about ventriloquism wow
this batman does a lot
but does he dance
[Music]
[Applause]
but this game isn't crusading solo he
has a whole cave full of allies
like alfred pennyworth butler of batman
but king of sick burns clayface is
losing his integrity
i wasn't aware that he ever had any to
begin with oh
robin the boy wonder as in boy i wonder
what screwed him up between this show
and titans
batgirl a college kid whose relationship
with bats is super creepy after you've
seen the killing joke movie
barbara come in you've grown ew
and commissioner gordon a humble civil
servant tormented by a billionaire
psychopath determined to drive him
insane
batman busy night helen get me
we need to talk
nick was making a comeback
[Music]
come on give him a break bats we all
know you're a ninja you don't have to
keep proving into grandpa cop all right
jeez together they'll protect gotham
a city trapped somewhere between 1932
and 1992
a town where the crime is up the nights
are long
and the people are rectangles it's a
city under siege from the best rogues
gallery in animation history
featuring character-defining portrayals
of two-face you're talking to the wrong
harvey mr freeze to never again
walk on a summer's day with a hot wind
in your face
and a warm hand to hold harley quinn
harley quinn pleased to meet you the
best joker ever
yeah i said it
and a bad menagerie's worth of animals
[Music]
geez bad man maybe you should stick to
something less threatening like a
penguin
[Music]
so light up the bat signal and revisit
the highs
i am vengeance i am the knight i
am batman and the lows
you've made her a monster i believe she
would disagree
of the darkest adaptation of batman ever
made literally the darkest
because they drew it on black paper that
wasn't afraid to hit kids with complex
philosophy
santayana says that those who forget the
past are condemned to repeat it
then break it up with a guy kicking a
werewolf in the face if it's a fight
you're looking for
try starting one with me cdc
that's all we want a definitive portrait
of a beloved character that balances
multiple tones across dozens of hours
that can only happen with a perfect
creative team and lands at the perfect
time in the cultural zeitgeist
is that so hard starring
hygiene related insults listen up
scumwad
here's how it works slime ball all right
scum bucket
too late dirt bag breaking and entering
what do you want as professor crane lost
his appetite
who's back there you just
terrible marksmanship
maniacal laughter
[Music]
batman's o face
gas attacks gas attacks
gotham city exploding
stop shooting you lunatic we're sitting
on a powder tank
and batman thumbs up dot jeff nope the
other one
that's the one
this batman forever
okay we need to talk about the intro for
a sec has anyone else noticed that the
crooks are just two guys who happen to
be walking past the bank at night
then when the entrance explodes they run
away like any sane person would do
they don't even have any loot on them
sure fine they pull guns on batman but
for all they know he's the psycho going
around blowing up banks
and batman doesn't know who did it
either he had to drive there but does
that stop him from beating the crap out
of him and leaving him for the cops
without any evidence to convict him on
this is why vigilantes are a bad idea
you guys
candyman five times into a mirror
spooky scary skeletons and shivers down
my spine
who will survive and what will be left
of them
eyes lungs pancreas so many snacks
so little time